Democrats finally realizing that Kamala
Harris is a lost cause much like Jesse
high-ranking Libs casting data in our
political future while leaking their
grievances to the New York Times They
think Harris is a political liability
and admit that they've lost hope in her
one big wig donor that's somebody with
big hair sums up the situation this way
I can't think of one thing she's done
except stay out of the way and stand
beside him at certain ceremonies
but how could you lose hope in this
we will devise metrics and be very clear
and I thank the university and and
Michelle for the work that has been
happening to help us articulate the
metrics by which we will then measure
our success in real time not waiting for
years down the line but in real time
measure our success
where are the Bongos but you really hit
rock bottom when two-time election loser
Hillary thinks you're toast Hill saying
privately that Harris would not be able
to win an election because she does not
possess the necessary political
instincts to get through a primary Dana
I posited a theory to you this morning
do you remember what that is that
basically she is doing a brilliant job
of taking all the heat off Joe like like
uh Kamala is basically the Donald Trump
for the Press she's replacing them him
yeah or is he does he go by them are
they
but do you agree with me
I've been thinking about it Greg and I'm
not sure because a lot of people thought
she was the one who tipped off the media
to the leaked story about the documents
next to the Corvette yes I know I don't
think that she leaked those at all but I
do think she benefited from a month of
not having any scrutiny but then just
like clockwork there's only two types of
stories for Kamala Harris there's the
reboot story like oh she's getting a
makeover she hired new people everything
is going to be great she's really going
to do it this time and that's quickly
followed by like today the stories that
says wow all the Democrats are really
worried about her prospects and what I
thought was just really difficult it
must be hard to read if you're in the
vice president's office let alone her
the vice president is that her press
office gave to reporters a list of
people that they should call because
those people were supposedly going to
say really nice things about Kamala
Harris and those people declined to do
it wow that's brutal and that hurts
right so as it comes first and you kind
of really feel bad for her to do that
but here's the thing
it's so bad for her that even with
Biden's numbers being what they are and
I think Judge Jeanine rattled through a
couple of them and they are the numbers
are not good but even with that there's
nobody there saying well well we should
really maybe give Biden's number two a
second look they're not doing that oh
you don't want to take a second look at
Biden's number two you know um since we
are in these boxes I will refer to
Harold as Mike Brady
um doesn't this feel Mike doesn't this
feel like an orchestrated hit like
you know she she's an easy target and
she's not only a kind of a public pinata
for Republicans increasingly it looks
like Democrats as well look I I don't
know if she is is going to be the
nominee at some point for the party and
I don't know if if she will recover from
all of these things but what I do know
is she's smart uh she is a good if not a
very good lawyer and I believe she has
political instincts but if she doesn't
do one of two things and I think you
have to do both She's Gotta Give us a
plan on the border because she was put
in charge of that and I think she could
uh capitalize on things she does best
and when you when you're in a weak spot
politically you got to figure out
something the things you do best and
amplify that she was a crime fighter in
California go out as we've talked about
in this show and figure out ways in
which we reform bail reform or undo it
and how we equip police Chiefs and
police departments around the country
with the tools they need to fight crime
the right way and the Safe Way in
communities and not discriminate against
communities if she does that it'll go a
long way to towards silencing some of
the criticism and frankly helping to
rebound her political efforts all right
well thank you Mike Brady let's go to
Carol Brady is that me at the table yes
I've never been called Carol but I'm
delighted listen Kamala Harris has the
opportunity that most women in this
country would give their right hand for
it she is vice president to a president
who's 80 years old and on his way out
cognitively okay she could give the
middle finger to everyone in America who
said you were picked for identity
politics if she could only show that
she's at least half competent the woman
hasn't had an interview in a year since
she messed up with Lester Holt now let's
talk about how she could prove herself
she could prove herself she's given this
border issue right how tough is that the
root causes everybody knows she could go
out there and say this country is the
greatest country in the world that's why
everyone wants to come here we are the
epitome of what people want and where
they want to live border patrol agents
do a great job we've got to give them
credit and by the way the dreamers we
should give them citizenship we should
do that for them we should have
immigrants but that has to be legal we
should vet these people American
citizens need to be protected she's a
former D.A she can get all this stuff
out but she can't get it out because
she's too lazy to get herself out there
and focus on the issues and for Hillary
Clinton to dump on her is really in the
epitome of someone who's who's really
lost it and incapable and I'm tired of
Simone Sanders saying she's doing this
because she is facing a historic set of
challenges because she's the first
African-American women look a lot of us
were the first of a lot of things and
what you do is you just do it better
than the other guy and be confident and
prove to Americans are there for them
and that's the end of it so uh can I
call you cousin Oliver please yes uh how
do you feel about this do you feel that
it's an orchestrated hit I do I feel
like we're watching a slow motion and
painful
attempt to surgically remove
Kamala Harris from the ticket you
remember the game Operation yes and you
have these little tweezers and you try
to get in there and you try to and then
it's because if they hit something this
the women are going to get upset blacks
are going to get upset they got to be
very careful when they take Kamala off
this ticket and this is coordinated and
it's calculated it starts with
Pocahontas remember and then you go
Washington Post talk to 30 Democrats
around the country she doesn't have it
and then you have the New York Times
drops a major well-sourced hit piece
crooked gets in there says she lacks
political insects and then James Clyburn
the king maker Mr South Carolina Joe's
guy he was the one who had so much juice
he got katangi brown Jackson on the
court and he goes not only do you guys
you know it's Joe's decision whatever
he's comfortable with he takes it a step
further than Pocahontas he goes I didn't
really want Kamal on the ticket to begin
with
so Kamala is probably looking around
clane's gone she's got no allies you
need allies in Washington she's in
trouble yeah wow it is orchestrated
you've convinced me I wanna Brian kill
Mead I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now